I'm David. I'll be telling you today about how we can leverage
cryptographic tools for genome privacy.
Uh, this talk is based on a lot of joint works with my adviser Dan,
as well as Computational Biologists here at Stanford.
So, Gill Bejerano, Karthik Jagadeesh, Johannes Bigmeier,
as well as biologists at MIT,
this is Bonnie Berger's group and the student that's Hyunghoon Cho.
Great. So, the kinds of problems that we're interested in exploring in
this space is problems like the following: what gene caused a specific rare disease?
At first glance it seems like a purely biology problem.
So, why is it at a security or privacy workshop?
So, allow me to explain.
The set up is roughly as follows;
suppose we have a group of patients who all happen to have a particular genetic disorder.
For this talk, take as a concrete example the case of Kabuki Syndrome.
So, we have a group of patients who all happen to have Kabuki Syndrome [NOISE].
Now, let me also provide a little bit of biology background.
A human genome consists of about 10,
20,000 protein encoding genes.
Genes that are actually responsible for dictating specific protein functionalities,
and individuals both you and I,
as well as these patients in our group,
have about 200 to 400 of these so-called rare variants;
places in their genome that differ from the canonical reference human genome.
So, the way that we can abstractly model it is as follows;
for each patient, we can associate with them a gene vector of dimension 20,000.
One component associated with each gene in
a protein encoding genome and each patient will have a
one in a particular position if they have a rare variant in that gene and zero otherwise.
So, once we formulated the problem in this way,
the task of identifying the gene that is
responsible for a particular disease is essentially
identifying a gene that has
the most common or varied number of
variants across all of the patients in a disease group.
In this concrete example here,
it will be gene number two because four out of the five patients in
our disease group have a rare mutation in that particular gene.
While this analysis might seem very simple,
it actually tends to work surprisingly well for a very broad class of
genetic diseases mainly the class of Mendelian or monogenic diseases.
Diseases that are caused by a mutation in a single gene.
These diseases are actually quite common and are estimated to a-
to affect up to 10 percent of the population.
So, so far, if we want to,
to diagnose Mendelian diseases,
it seems very straightforward.
All we have to do is gather up s-
a collection of patients who all happen to have a disease,
sequence their genomes and then perform this analysis where we identify the common gene.
However, there are some complications in practice.
Today, patients often live in
geographically diverse areas and because of a focus on rare diseases,
any single medical institution or hospital might only have one or two patients.
They don't have sufficient data to carry out the analysis needed.
As a result, in order to perform these computations,
patients essentially have to entrust their genome to
some central facility or some trusted party who will then carry out this computation.
Today, due to patient privacy concerns,
as well as legal and regulatory barriers that exist that prevent
faci- institutions and facilities from directly sharing genomic data.
These kinds of analyses are actually very difficult to carry out,
and for a good reason,
a patient's genome is highly sensitive and if revealed,
not only compromises their own individual privacy,
but also the privacy of their relatives and their next of kin
and can open them up to subsequent fraud or discrimination.
As such, the natural question that ca- that biologists came to us with is whether we can
hope to perform these kinds of computations but alleviate some of these privacy concerns.
Can we perform these useful scientific computations but without getting
direct access to the complete patient genomes of all of the different individuals?
Here, the problem becomes a cryptographic one.
And in this talk, I will tell you about
how modern cryptographic tools enable us to suppress these scientific challenges.
Using cryptography, we're going to,
the solution will look roughly as follows.
We're going to first assume that we have access to
two entities that don't oftentimes collude with one another.
For instance, you can consider a hospital in the United States and a hospital in Europe,
and once we have these two non-colluding entities,
it actually becomes much easier to make progress on this problem.
What we can do is something along the following,
each patient will take their genome and do what's called a secret
sharing of their genome and send each share to each of these two hospitals.
What this means concretely is the following,
each patient will generate a random vector and send it to one of the hospitals.
That a random vector has nothing to do with their genome,
and to the other hospital,
it will send a difference between the random vector and their genome.
So, notice that in a very strong information theoretic sense,
each individual hospital learns
absolutely no information about the contents of any individual genome.
Of course together they're able to reconstruct the full information and
that's what is going to enable us to perform useful computations on that data.
So, in this way,
all of the patients in our disease group will contribute
and secretly share their data across the two institutions,
and after all of the data has been aggregated,
what the two hospitals are going to do is engage in what's
called a cryptographic multiparty computation protocol,
or MPC protocol, on the pooled inputs.
What this essentially entails is a message passing protocol.
So, these two hospitals are going to exchange a sequence of
messages such that at the end of the protocol execution,
what they each of them learn is basically the top most
frequently occurring variant across all of the patients in a disease group.
When we actually perform these kinds of computations on actual patient data,
we're able to successfully reconstruct and identify the known cause of the disease.
Moreover, the security and privacy, uh,
requirements that we can then satisfy is
that all of the hospitals and all of the patients
only learn the single or
the top two or three variants that are most common across all of them.
They do not learn the other 200 to 400 rare variants that
any patient might have that might serve as a genetic fingerprint for that patient.
That- and all that information is highly sensitive and is kept
completely confidential as a result of these computations.
Our, the techniques I described here actually pertain,
are applied, are applicable more broadly to many different scenarios.
So, I've started by describing one such scenario where we have a this group
of patients and our goal is to identify a causal gene that,
uh, afflict all of these different patients.
But we can also consider other scenarios in
the genomic space where our techniques apply equally well.
For instance, we might have two hospitals who want to,
who might want to identify,
to see if they have any patients with common rare mutations or rare variants.
These might allow them to develop common treatment plans and so forth to
facilitate the diagnosis and treatment of complex diseases.
In other cases we might have, uh,
analyses where we want to find
a mutation that appears in a child but not in any of the patients.
Again, cryptographic techniques enable us to
perform these kinds of useful scientific computations, and again,
all of these examples might seem very simple but to
showcase that this is actually a very useful scientific computation,
let me emphasize that using our techniques,
we were actually able to discover a previously unidentified pathological variant,
and subsequent tests with biologists at the Stanford School of Medicine was actually to be
able to confirm that we actually made a useful and relevant scientific discovery.
So, these techniques if deployed,
can essentially and significantly improve the amount of patient privacy
we can get and still facilitate these very useful scientific computations.
Let me just briefly say a few words about the efficiency of our protocol.
To simulate these two non-colluding cloud entities,
we basically set up one server on
the East Coast and one server on the West Coast of the US,
and we basically measure the amount of time and computation needed in order to run one of
these protocols for identifying a causal gene across a small disease cohort.
What you can see is for a modest number of patients somewhere between 10 and 100,
uh, the R protocol is quite efficient, namely the computation,
the end-to-end protocol execution time basically is under 20 seconds and it
only a modest amount of communication is needed on the orders of tens of megabytes.
Let me preface here that for many cases where we have rare diseases,
small disease cohorts is actually,
uh, sufficient to perform these analyses.
In all of our concrete experiments,
five to 10 patients was actually sufficient and for these types of, uh,
scenarios our protocols are highly efficient and serve to,
uh, make the necessary st-, uh, scientific discoveries.
Now, you might wonder, everything I've talked about so
far is related to rare disease diagnosis.
But what if we want to understand the genetics of cancer,
or find the genetic causes of like of
cau- more common phenotypes like high blood pressure.
So in a subsequent work with,
uh, folks at MIT,
we looked at performing even a much larger scale analyses to also
identify the genetic causes of more complex diseases and,
uh, conditions like high blood pressure or cancer and so forth.
The cau- the genetic tool that's often used here is what's called a
Genome-Wide Association studies or GWAS, for short,
and oftentimes the focus is on identifying the complex interactions
that underlie things like cancer and other more common diseases.
There are many challenges that arise when we have to extend
our multi-party computation frameworks to handle the large number of
patients and tease out these more complex and weaker signals.
For instance, oftentimes we have to work with upwards of 10,000 to
over a million individuals in order to actually obtain useful scientific results.
We often oftentimes have to correct for
population-level effects because when we
have millions of individuals and millions of patients,
sometimes deviations could just be caused by one's ancestry.
These could cause large correlations with the disease status but
actually are not actually responsible for the condition we're exploring.
So, we have to develop algorithmic techniques to filter out these kinds of
population-level effects and develop them in
a way that's amenable to modern cryptographic tools.
I won't have time to go into the details.
Let me just give you the high-level conclusion.
Well, our work actually gives the first end-to-end protocol
to perform these kind of Genome-Wide Association studies.
For about 25,000 individuals,
we were able to complete this entire protocol with about three days of computation.
This might seem like a lot,
but when you consider typical scientific computations,
to just get access to that data,
oftentimes takes 90 days or something like that.
So, where we are able to perform
useful scientific studies that are able to identify genetic causes of certain diseases,
computing in something like three days is actually well within this realm of reason.
So, the high-level takeaway that I want you
to understand from the first part of this talk,
is that using modern cryptographic tools we can actually enable useful computations while
protecting and maintaining the privacy of
the individual genomes that go into these kinds of computations.
Let me also emphasize here that I'm really just using genomics as
one particular use case of the more general paradigm in cryptography,
but very often the techniques that we develop and use here can
actually be applied to very general computations over private data.
So, you have scenarios, for instance,
in machine learning where it in the IoT space,
where you actually need to do computations on private data.
Many of our techniques can actually be useful and
I'm very happy to talk to you about those if you're interested.
So, in the remaining time I have left, I'm going to demystify,
and show you some of the magic that goes on in constructing these cryptographic protocols.
How do we do computations on private inputs?
And as the one concrete example that I'm going to give you,
is this Yao's protocol,
for doing two-party computation.
This is a beautiful protocol due to Andrew Yao and it dates back even to the 1980s.
So, it's very impressive that a lot of these protocols and these ideas were
really around since the dawn of cryptography and today they're actually being,
uh, applicable and useful for addressing a lot of the privacy challenges we face today.
So, Yao's protocol is a classic protocol for two-party computation.
Namely, there are two computing parties and they each have some private inputs.
Maybe we have two hospitals,
and these are the vectors they hold are
sort of the rare variants that occur among the patients within that hospital,
and their goal is like to compute some joint function on
their private inputs such that at the end of the computation
the only thing that is revealed to the two hospitals is the results
of the computation and whatever can be inferred from those results.
So if the computation itself is very leaky or reveals a lot of information,
we perhaps we should not be performing those kinds of computations.
But if we design the computation carefully,
we've outlined a relev- a reasonable mechanism that provides a valid privacy and
functionality trade-off we can actually perform
these computations without revealing any additional information.
Let me now describe for you,
how this protocol execution works.
Typically, we're going to denote one of the parties as
the garbler and one of them as the evaluator.
The reasons for these names will become clear subsequently in this talk.
Let me just, um, note here that Yao's protocol is also called a garble circuit protocol.
So, if you've, if you've heard that name before,
this is what is referring to.
So, in our first step of the computation,
what we're going to do, is we're going to model that computation as a Boolean circuit.
So, we're going to express it as a sequence of logic gates where the inputs
to this Boolean circuit are the inputs of each of the individual parties.
So, some of the wires here labeled in green are pertained to party one
and some that are labeled in orange are held by party number two.
So, the output of the computation is going to be
computed by this digital- by this logic circuit.
And the second step of the protocol now is one of these designated parties namely,
the garbler, is going to essentially prepare an encryption of the circuit,
or a garbling of the circuit and it's going to be done in
a very special way to enable the evaluator,
to subsequently learn the output of the computation on the input of its choosing.
The way it works is as follows,
the garbler is going to start by choosing
two different symmetric encryption keys for every wire in the circuit, right?
So each, we have a bunch of input wires,
we have intermediate wires and then we have output wires.
So first, the garbler is going to choose
two encryption keys for the first wire of the circuit,
and it's going to proceed likewise.
So, every single wire in a circuit has
two different keys associated with it. Why two keys?
Well, essentially each key is going to be associated with
a particular value that can be the value of that particular wire, right?
We're talking about Boolean circuits,
but that means all of the inputs are binary value,
the 0 1 values,
and all of the intermediate wires that you sort of evaluate
each gate of a circuit is also a 0 1 value.
So, each key can essentially be associated with a one single wire value.
That's why we have two keys for each wire,
one for the value zero for that wire,
one for the value one, for that particular wire.
So, now let me describe for you how we actually
encrypt or garble each of the gates in the circuit.
The protocol is going to proceed gate by gate.
So every gate is going to be prepared as follows.
Let's focus on one particular gate, an AND gate,
first what we're going to do,
is we're going to look at the truth table for this AND gate.
So just to recall, in an AND gate,
the output wire is one if and only if both of the input wires are equal to one.
So, on the right half of the slide,
I've written down the truth table of the AND gate,
where the inputs are contributed by parties one and two,
and the output is just the AND of the two input bits.
Now recall that, for every wire in a circuit,
I've associated with them two different keys.
Okay, so I'm going to just write down the keys associated
with the input wires as well as the output wires.
And the key idea now,
we're essentially going to encrypt the output key with the two input keys, okay?
So, let me show you this as a picture.
Let's take the first row in this truth table.
So, both the inputs are zero,
the output is also zero.
So, what we're going to do is we're going to encrypt the key associated
with the value zero for the output wire, uh,
here denoted by k_0 out,
and we're going to encrypt it using the two keys corresponding to the input value.
So, parties one input value is zero,
party two's input value is also zero,
and we're going to do proceed likewise.
So, for every row in the truth table,
we're going to produce a ciphertext,
and the ciphertext is going to be encrypted using two different keys where
the choice of the two keys depends on the corresponding values for those input wires.
And now we're simply going to shuffle the rows of this table randomly, okay?
So, we're gonna randomly permute the ordering of the ciphertext,
uh, for each garbled table.
Now observe, how do we do evaluation?
What we're going to do is we're going to somehow,
and I haven't explained how,
but give the evaluator this garbled table as well as ensure that
the evaluator only has a single key for every single input wire for the circuit.
Now, notice that if the evaluator has a single key for each wire,
it can decrypt exactly one of the rows in this table,
namely the row corresponding to its particular input configuration.
In this case, the evaluator has
the key for the bit one for party one's input for the green input,
and the bit zero for party two's input.
So, it is able to decrypt the first row of this table.
So, what that looks like is the evaluator takes its key.
It unlocks the first ciphertext,
and then it unlocks the second component and out pops the output key.
So, if we ensure that the evaluator has
exactly one key for every wire in the input layer,
the construction of the garbling process ensures that the evaluator can essentially
learn one key for every wire in the intermediate circuit as well as the output circuit.
And this is what allows the evaluator to perform the evaluation process.
Notice that when the evaluator obtains the output key,
the output value, this is just a random symmetric key,
just another cryptographic key.
It has no semantic meaning,
the key itself does not say the value is zero.
So, essentially what the evaluator can do is that it obtains a new key,
but it doesn't really know whether this key
corresponds to the value of zero or the value one.
And this is how we're going to get privacy.
Okay? So, the overall protocol will roughly go as follows.
The Garbler is gonna prepare its garbled circuits,
and is going to send the garbled tables as well as
the keys for its input to the evaluator.
There's one more step that's missing here.
How does the evaluator obtain the keys for its input?
Because the evaluator also participates in the computation,
it needs to provide some set of keys in order to actually
decrypt the entries in these garbled tables and compute their responses.
But, there's one final ingredient which is the notion of an oblivious transfer protocol.
I'm just gonna describe it abstractly here.
I'm not going to give you the concrete details,
but roughly what the setup is as follows.
Here we have a Garbler.
The Garbler chose two keys for every wire in the circuit.
So, for all of the wires that are contributed by the other party,
by the evaluator, it has two keys,
but it doesn't know which key to give to the evaluator.
Because that depends on the evaluator's input.
So, what an oblivious transfer protocol does is it enables
the evaluator to choose exactly one of the two keys,
and in particular it allows it to obtain a single key for its chosen input.
So in this case, if the evaluator's input is the value one,
it is going to request the one key.
So, an oblivious proto- transfer protocol enables precisely that computation.
It allows the evaluator to obtain the key corresponding to its input,
namely the key one for this concrete example,
while ensuring that the Garbler learns
no information about which key the evaluator chose.
So in this way, we can actually implement and
ob- secure computation protocol for arbitrary functionalities,
uh, and, uh, as follows.
So, in the first round of the protocol,
the evaluator is going to send an OT message when
an oblivious transfer message asking for the keys corresponding to its input.
And then the Garbler is going to reply with
the garbled circuits is going to reply with the keys for its input.
And then finally, the responses to the oblivious transfer query that
enables the evaluator to learn the keys for its input,
while revealing no additional information to the Garbler.
Then the evaluator can just simply use these keys
every time it has the two- it has the keys for the inputs,
it can obtain the key for the output and it can
proceed likewise gate by gate through the circuit,
eventually, receiving the output.
This is a very basic description of Yao's protocol,
and the ensuing 35 years since the introduction of Yao's protocol,
many improvements have been proposed.
And today, this is actually a highly efficient protocol for that
enables many different kinds of secure computation.
Uh, so, protocol is extremely efficient.
Uh, the main bottleneck today is in terms of the communication.
So, the unfortunate thing is that the garble circuit can be very, very big, right?
Because if you think about it,
every single gate in the circuit consists of two ciphertext,
consist of a small number of ciphertext.
And this can quickly add up depending on the magnitude
and the complexity of the computation of interest,
but the evaluation time and the garbling time is actually very fast.
So just to come back to the original picture,
I hope I sort of demystify what some of what goes
on in these multiparty computation protocols.
So using these kinds of protocols and these kinds of tools,
we can actually enable useful computations while
retaining the privacy of individual genomic data.
For instance, in our scenarios,
we oftentimes represent the computation as a Boolean circuit,
and then we run an instantiation of Yao's protocol.
For other scenarios, such as the large scale Genome-Wide Association problem,
we use different, uh, multiparty computation protocols.
And these will vary depending on the nature of the computation,
what kind of protocols we would like to use to achieve what kind of
efficiency and performance, uh, constraints.
So again, as a high level picture,
I hope I've demonstrated to you that using
some of these new kinds of cryptographic techniques,
we can actually inpu- perform
useful scientific computations while
preserving the privacy of the underlying genomic data.
And to conclude, if you're interested in learning more, our papers are available.
It was published in Science earlier last year.
We have a complete implementation if you're interested in exploring and playing around
with the code and there'll be an upcoming paper appearing in Nature Biotech,
hopefully, this month or next month, uh,
on doing the large scale privacy preserving
Genome-Wide Association Studies. Thank you very much. [APPLAUSE]
I have to say
that D- David is my first student to actually
graduate with papers in science and biotech.
It's, uh, ver- very cool.
Any, any questions on this?
[NOISE] So, for the protocol that you're using for the Genome-Wide Association Study-
Um-hmm, yes.
-is it secure again, i- is it, uh,
does it require that every party defect or wha-
what's the guarantees on the number of defectors you tolerate?
Uh, right. So, in all of these protocols we're working
in the so-called "two-Cloud scenario" where all of
the parties will secret share thei-
their data to these two Cloud service and they're trusted not to collude.
So, it's possible that one of the Clouds is malicious,
but as long as they're not sharing their data,
then we're- we have security, right?
And certainly in subsequent works we're trying to relax the model and gets,
uh, stronger, uh, security.
But, this is one of the first step.
Er, for the second part, the Genome-Wide Association Study,
did you just use this multiparty computation a- also differential privacy.
And if so, how do these two methods [OVERLAPPING] scaling property?
Right. It's an excellent question.
So, for the focus of this work,
we were looking at primarily cryptographic, uh, solutions.
So, there's been a lot of other work also by the same lab at MIT.
So, Bonnie Berger's group does a lot of work on this.
Looking at using differential privacy techniques, also for GWAS.
So, these provide different kind of tradeoffs.
And I think one of the nice things about it is that
differential privacy is also very compatible with the cryptographic framework.
So we can ad- add noise either at the beginning or at the end of the computations
in order to also implement a differential privacy mechanism on top of the cryptography.
So, these are not mutually exclusive,
and they provide different kinds of security guarantees.
So, for GWAS, I think differential privacy and crypto both are valid tools.
For the first task of doing these rare disease diagnosis,
differential privacy is less suitable because we often have very small number of patients
and we're really looking for those rare, uh, events. Um-hmm.
So, what's the limits of this?
Are there things you wanna do that you can't do in using these techniques?
Well, I- well so these techniques themselves are very general.
So in principle, we can do arbitrary computations.
The question is, what kinds of complications can we do efficiently?
And there I think, we need a lot of more communication between so,
at least for the genomic space between
the computational biologists who sort of propose the kinds of
computations they would like to do and
the cryptographer sort of saying what kind of computations can we do efficiently.
And, er, I think the most interesting research
is sort of finding that interesting middle ground,
where we can do useful scientific computations,
but also at a scale, uh,
that enables useful scientific discoveries.
Any other questions?
Right. Thank you.
Thank you. [APPLAUSE]